it's the end of the year so it's time to
take a look back on the best of the best
from the last 12 months here are the
five best PlayStation games of 2022 as
selected by Gamespot as well as five
honorable mentions that you can't afford
to miss
[Music]
[Applause]
PlayStations right at the end of the
year is God of War Ragnarok the highly
anticipated follow-up to 2018's God of
War in Ragnarok Kratos and his son
atreus are up against their deadliest
foe yet the end of the world itself but
that's not all with both fearful of a
prophecy that Kratos will die at the end
of their Adventure Father and Son must
learn to accept each other for who they
are and learning that loving someone
deeply means that eventually you might
have to let them go Ragnarok tells a
heart-wrenching story trust me you'll
cry a couple of times and its combat is
as frenetic and crunchy as ever with
both Kratos and atreus slashing through
anyone who dares to try and get in their
way with unmatched brutality whether
they be run-of-the-mill draggers or even
the Norse gods themselves God of War
Ragnarok earned a 9 out of 10 in our
review with Timor Hussein saying God of
War ragnarok's most impressive
achievements are its exploration of loss
and love grief and growth determinism
and Defiance it's an astoundingly
well-written game that deconstructs the
mythology of Norse gods and rebuilds it
as an odyssey about families
stray isn't just the game that we fell
in love with it's the one that our cats
fell in love with too affectionately
known as the cat game stray went viral
this summer when people were posting
videos of their own pets reacting to the
game's adorable fluffy protagonist stray
is a puzzle Adventure game where you
take on the role of a stray cat who has
been separated from its family with the
help of a handy drone named B12 you
navigate through a dilapidated City
that's full of robots run away from
Aliens and get up to a lot of cat
Mischief we gave stray a 9 out of 10
with reviewer Alessandra Barbosa
specifically calling out that a lot of
the enjoyment throughout stray's run
time comes from how well each scenario
is designed for the abilities of its
feline hero stray expertly embodies the
abilities of its feline protagonist to
create a captivating puzzle Adventure in
an engrossing post-apocalyptic world
Horizon forbidden West launched at the
beginning of 2022 and as the sequel to
2017's Horizon zero Dawn it picks up
protagonist eloy's quest to save the
world you know that small job after
defeating the Rogue Hades AI at the end
of zero Dawn the Planet needs a little
more help to recover completely a
mysterious blight is sweeping across the
world and so Eloy must gather allies to
find some ancient Tech to set things
straight if you enjoyed the original
there's plenty for you to enjoy in its
sequel from eloy's Motley Crew who are
helping her fix the world to more
interesting and varied side quests set
in locations like San Francisco and Las
Vegas our reviewer Phil hornshaw gave it
an 8 out of 10 saying that Horizon
forbidden West sometimes packs in so
much that it gets in its own way but the
many well-drawn characters populating
its quests keep it compelling
sifu is a game that will truly test your
might as its clever fighting mechanics
are easy to grasp but tough to master
upon death you revive but with a Twist
you're a few years older with age comes
more strength but less life in your
health bar and getting too old ends the
game the highlight of sifu is its combat
a dance of dodging blocking and
attacking but only when the moment is
right our review at Richard Wakeling
called sifu an excellent modern beat em
up with deep combat mechanics and a
fascinating aging system that sets it
apart from its contemporaries by
altering the way you progress from one
chapter to the next he gave it a 9 out
of 10.
there are many reasons that naughty
dog's 2013 title The Last of Us has
endured as a classic for all these years
it's an emotionally gutting story told
through fantastic performances that
still resonates with players today
following its PS3 and PS4 releases and
with an HBO series on the horizon
Naughty Dog work to bring the game to
PlayStation 5 in 2022 not content with
just adding a visual overhaul Naughty
Dog added a bunch of new features to
this Edition including new game modes
display modes skins and visual filters
new trophies and crucially a whole host
of fantastic accessibility features so
more people can play The Last of Us Part
One sadly is missing the original game's
multiplayer mode but our reviewer Jake
Decker said The Last of Us Part 1
manages to tell a harrowing story of
loss and Redemption that still holds up
despite some of its dated level design
those were games what's 5 best
PlayStation games of 2022 but since
you've been good this year here are five
more
speaking of naughty dog it makes another
appearance on this list with the
Uncharted Legacy of Thieves collection
it bundles together Uncharted 4 and Lost
Legacy and both games have been updated
for PS5 so they feature dual Sims haptic
feedback quicker loading performance and
Performance Plus modes as well as 3D
audio Uncharted 4 one of the games
included in this collection earned a
rare 10 out of 10 from us back in 2016
with Mike mahadi calling out the game's
cinematography in particular claiming
that both in cutscenes and out it
amplifies The Wonder of its gorgeous
World Lost Legacy is a fantastic
Standalone Adventure that caps off the
whole Saga and is well worth your time
ghost wire Tokyo is the latest game from
Tango Gameworks the studio founded by
Master of horror Shinji makami while
ghostwire certainly leans into the
supernatural it's not full of Spooks
making for an enjoyable adventure around
a desolate Tokyo that submerged in fog
as Akito with help from KK a spirit
who's inhabiting his body it's up to you
to find out what's going on while its
side missions are a little inconsistent
its open world is beautiful and fun to
explore thanks to the game's truly
unique combat system in our 8 out of 10
review Richard Wakeling said that
ghostwire Tokyo's sheer creativity and
attention to detail exhibited throughout
constantly shine through
it wouldn't be a PlayStation best off
list without one of the platform's most
well-known franchises Gran Turismo the
latest gt7 launched earlier this year
earning a number of high review scores
including an 8 out of 10 from us with
reviewer Alex [ __ ] praising the game's
stunning visuals customization options
handling and load times while the core
game is great it's had a bit of a bumpy
go over the past few months with
controversies over its handling of
microtransactions online issues and
criticism over its roster however the
core racing experience is still
enjoyable and we think that earns it a
spot as one of our best PlayStation
games of the year
what would a skating game be like if the
main character had a gun you may find
yourself asking well Wonder no longer
because rollerdrome answers that very
specific question for you the latest
from olly olly World developers roll 7
launched earlier this year and it's a
single player roller skating game where
you balance maintaining momentum pulling
off tricks and taking out enemies that
spawn in the skate parks you're
practicing in it sounds like a lot to
keep track of but trust us you'll be
hitting that flow State and those score
multipliers in no time in his 8 out of
10 review Phil honshaw wrote developer
roll 7 excellently mixes high scoring
skating gameplay with shooter ideas to
make a hybrid game that's tough to put
down
of course I couldn't finish this list
without mentioning Elden ring the
overall Gamespot game of the year it may
not be a console exclusive but it's a
must-have regardless of platform it's an
open world done in from software fashion
so it's filled with wonder Discovery and
of course a whole host of enemies that
are ready to fight you at every turn in
his 10 out of 10 review Tamar Hussein
wrote in a genre that has become wrought
with bloated and over-designed games
Elden ring is defiantly contrarian in
almost every way it will go down in
history as one of the all-time greats a
Triumph in design and creativity and an
open world game that distinguishes
itself for what it doesn't do as much as
what it does and if that doesn't sell
you I'm not sure what will
those were all picks for the best
PlayStation games of 2022 if you want to
know the best Xbox switch and PC games
of the year make sure to subscribe to
Gamespot on YouTube or check out
gamespot.com we also have an in-depth
video on our game of the year Elden ring
and why it got that coveted prize you
can find me on Twitter at Lucy James
games and I'll see you next time
[Music]